القوات الروسيه تكثف قصفها من جديد في
اوكرانيا مسؤولون اوكرانيون اكدوا ان
موسكو شنت هجوما على مناطقه في جنوب
البلاد خلال ليله الاربعاء الخميس بواسطه
42 طائره مسيره وسته صواريخ ما اسفر عن
مقتل وجرح عدد من الاشخاص
خلال مؤتمره الصحفي السنوي صرح الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان القوات المسلحه
الروسيه تعزز مواقعها في
تعمل قواتنا المسلحه على طول خط التماس
دعنا نقول بكل تواضع انها تعمل على تعزيز
مواقعها جميع القوات المسلحه تقريبا في
المرحله النشطه من العمليات ووضع قواتنا
يتحسن ويتقدم في كل
مكان الجيش الاكراني قال ايض ان روسيا
هجمت البنيه التحتيه للموانئ في منطقه
الدنوب وان الحطام دمر مستودعات منشاتين
لتخزين الحبوب وهناك مخاوف براي المراقبين
بان تضرب موسكو بقوه في وقت يبدو فيه ان
قدره الغربيين على دعم اوكرانيا تضعف بعد
عامين على اندلاع
الحرب